hi today I want to talk about how to
fall in love with the language now you
might be wondering why I use the term
falling in love with the language
because normally fall in love we use it
when we want to talk about falling in
love with a person but actually falling
in love with a person and falling in
love with the language have a lot of
similar features first it's a long-term
relationship and it entails time energy
sometimes it's accelerating sometimes it
can be a little bit frustrating but the
real point is that in order to fall in
love you have to know why you have to
have a spark which is ignited and I want
to talk today about how my spark for
hungarian was ignited in 2007 I was
there I visited Hungary actually
Budapest for the first time with my
friends and I found the city absolutely
beautiful but the thing that struck me
was not the fact that the Butte I was
not only struck with the beauty of the
of the city I was struck by the
experiences I had for the good and for
the bad I had one of the best dancing
nights of my life as I described in the
article you can you can check the the
link below if you want to read it and I
also had some bad experiences like for
example being taken for a Syrian refugee
and being interrogated at the airport or
being pepper sprayed by some bouncers
but this didn't keep me from you know
getting a yearning getting infatuated
with a language and it was infatuated
was still not love you know that
Hungarian is considered as the hardest
language of the world or one of the
hardest languages of the world but to
bear with the love metaphor let's
suppose that you are a party and you're
a guy and you see a very beautiful girl
and you tell yourself I will never get
that girl and your friend actually
reinforces that conviction by saying and
it's she's too beautiful for you that's
the same thing as saying that somebody
says that a language is too hard to get
too hard to learn and you delude
yourself into thinking that that's
actually true yeah but you have to
listen to your inner voice and if you
find a spark if you're really fall in
love with a person the fact that she is
too beautiful for you or a language
being too hard doesn't count anymore
that's what really counts and in order
to ignite that spark you have to find a
reason if you haven't found a solid
reason or solid reasons keep looking for
me one of the the things that push me
towards a language is not so much as how
it sounds that it does help its grammar
and stuff it's more about the
experiences that I have the things that
are represented by the language to me go
visit in the country and talking to
people and having experiences is the
most important thing even before the the
language itself and it really depends on
the individual to be that for you
reading a book of history of that
country or like you like the food or you
talk to a person can be the igniting
spark and everybody is different but
once again you have to keep looking and
you have to know exactly why you want to
embark on this romantic story
this is absolutely important and another
thing is that it's a long it's a
long-term project so to say it's a
long-term quest so you have to give it
daily care and so much as you give daily
care to your partner you have to
understand how to give daily care to a
language in order to do that you have to
have some kind of plan you have to have
some kind of objective long-term goals
and for example for me Hungarian my
long-term goal is I want to reach
fluency in two years now what I what do
I mean by fluency fluency is a very
subjective term it if you want to see
it's clear the important things that
it's clear for me I give myself a
definition of fluence that you can check
my article about how to region 8 like
fluency to see what basic fluency in
fluency are for me and so if I have this
goal in two years I also can imagine my
trip backwards and I can think okay my
midterm goal is to reach basic fluency
one year and my short term goal is to
finish as Emil in four months and they
set a date so I have to start
point I have the final destination and I
can't imagine may trip backwards I
started learning and garen officially on
the 4th of December and I'm sorry for
the 4th of November and from that moment
on I knew that I would learn and give
data care to to Hungarian and also you
have to know how to keep this this love
story going so knowing exactly why is
the first step but you also have to know
how to deal with that so even if I'm
Goering is supposed to be a very hard
language is quite different from Italian
for my native Italian I know how exactly
how to deal with that because I apply my
method which is called bilingual I
called bilingual translation which I'm
applying to a gear and I'm having a
blast with it because I'm learning
faster than I have ever done with with
any other language so just to recap
falling in love with the language it's
like falling in love with a person it
follows some some important rules you
have to understand exactly why it
doesn't have to be just an infatuation
otherwise it might turn into some kind
of summer fling which disappears very
quickly and in order for the love story
to continue have to give it daily care
you have to know where you're going and
you have to know how you're going there
and to finish this
I wanted to quote Gary Chapman who said
that love is a choice that we make every
single day thanks for listening